[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Give me a minute,
and I'll show you how Anthos
can help you rapidly build
and deploy hybrid and
multi-cloud applications
without compromising security
or increasing complexity.
Anthos is a hybrid and
multi-cloud application
modernization platform.
Embracing open
standards, it lets
you run your apps unmodified
on existing on-prem hardware
or in public cloud, simply,
flexibly, and securely.
Can't wait to try it?
Set up your own
sample deployment
at goo.gle/tryAnthos.
Anthos enables
containerized microservices
architectural-based apps across
multiple platforms, clusters,
and locations.
It allows for consistent policy
and configuration management,
provides observability
through golden signals,
and delivers a Zero Trust
security model for your apps.
Anthos can be used to
re-platform virtual machines,
modernize existing
apps, applying
modern CI/CD principles,
and security,
reduce operational expenditure
with no vendor lock-in
So next time you're
thinking about hybrid
and multi-cloud
application platforms,
take a minute to look at Anthos.
For more info, check out
cloud.google.com/anthos.
[MUSIC PLAYING]